Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: eric vautier
Apprendre à se taire…
Vraiment ?
En êtes-vous sûr ?
Personnellement, j'hésite.
On raconte qu’un ancien président
de La Poste
aurait marqué son auditoire
par un silence prolongé
lors d’une importante réunion d’équipe.
Il arrive, devant le pupitre,
cinq secondes s’écoulent.
Il se tait.
Jusque-là, tout va bien, il sourit.
Il est heureux.
Nous aussi.
Dix secondes supplémentaires.
Puis dix autres.
Le public, comme vous,
commence à s’interroger :
« Mais pourquoi ne dit-il rien ? »
Une minute, une minute dix,
une minute trente.
On commence à tousser.
Certains trépignent sur leur chaise.
Une minute cinquante,
deux minutes trente, trois minutes
et toujours pas un son de la part
de celui qui est censé parler.
Le silence devient interminable.
Lorsque tout à coup,
le président de la Poste
se décide enfin à prendre la parole
et dit d’un air très calme,
totalement assumé :
« Mesdames et Messieurs,
vous venez de vivre
le temps d’attente
que subissent en moyenne nos clients
chaque fois qu'ils entrent
dans un bureau de poste.
Vous ne trouvez pas ça un peu long ? »
Effectivement.
Que nous raconte cette histoire ?
Elle nous fait entendre, je crois,
un silence très éloquent.
Plutôt que de tomber dans une énième
démonstration à force de courbes,
de chiffres, de mots, d’arguments,
ce chef d’entreprise a décidé de se taire
pour faire ressentir l’attente des clients
et la faire éprouver presque péniblement
par ses salariés.
Qu’est-ce que c’est intelligent !
Et évidemment, ils s’en souviennent tous !
Si nous avons tous besoin
des mots pour communiquer -
sinon, je ne serais pas là puisque
c’est avec ça que je parle avec vous -
n’oublions pas que le silence
aussi est une parole forte
qui nous permet de parler,
d’écouter, de nous parler.
Oui, il faut savoir se taire,
car le silence est
la clé d’un bon discours.
J’ai mis des années à le comprendre
mais c’est aujourd’hui pour moi
une évidence.
Il faut des silences avant un discours,
pendant et après.
Un peu comme ces couches de vanille
dans un mille-feuille,
mon dessert préféré.
Sans quoi votre discours
sera sec et monotone.
Un silence avant, disais-je.
Mais pourquoi se taire
alors qu’on est impatient de parler ?
C'est sûrement aussi votre cas.
Eh bien, parce que cela crée
le désir d'écouter.
Votre désir d'écouter, vous public.
On ne quémande pas le silence,
on l’obtient en se taisant, c’est la base.
Ensuite, disais-je, un silence,
ou plutôt une multitude de silences
au milieu de votre discours,
au milieu des arguments,
des phrases, des idées,
pour respirer,
pour mettre en avant vos mots chéris
comme des pépites, vos idées chères,
pour créer du suspense et de l’attention.
Comme Barack Obama sait si bien le faire.
En effet,
saviez-vous que l’ancien président
américain parlait très vite autrefois,
très, très vite ?
Il a appris à ralentir
et à poser sa voix
pour gagner en charisme et en autorité.
Et le résultat est là.
Rappelez-vous, rappelez-vous
son discours à Chicago en 2017,
où il brillait
par sa posture humble, forte,
sa gestuelle modeste, sa voix posée,
ce style qui le caractérise tant,
Et aussi ces phrases
entrecoupées de silences
qui nous font respirer.
Obama est un cheval au pas,
au trot,
jamais au galop.
Enfin, un silence s’impose
après votre dernier mot,
car comme disait Sacha Guitry,
« Le silence qui suit Mozart,
c’est encore du Mozart. »
Et votre auditoire a besoin
de ces quelques secondes d’accalmie
pour que vos mots s’imprègnent,
se greffent presque sur sa peau, en lui,
dans son cœur, dans sa tête,
pour que ça reste.
Alors, amusez-vous,
jouez des silences,
allongez-les, raccourcissez-les
comme des notes de musique,
tantôt brèves, tantôt longues.
Amusez-vous.
Oui, il faut savoir se taire.
Car le silence est aussi
la clé de l’improvisation.
Aujourd’hui, vous le savez comme moi,
on nous demande de parler tout le temps,
à tout bout de champ,
de savoir réagir vite et fort,
d’avoir réponse à tout,
de ne jamais rester muet.
Mais j’ai une question à vous poser :
vous, comment faites-vous
pour improviser sans en avoir l’air ?
Aha, pas simple !
Là encore, le silence est un sésame,
un formidable sésame.
Il vous permet de rassembler vos idées
le temps de monter l’escalier
qui vous mène jusqu’à votre cerveau.
Il vous permet d’avoir l’air posé et calme
alors qu’en fait, je bous à l’intérieur,
vous vous en doutez.
Il vous permet d'avoir l'air intelligent,
quand bien même vous cherchez vos idées.
Et surtout, il permet d’éradiquer
ces satanés « euh »,
vous savez, ces « euh »,
ces petits ral-EUH
qui parasit-EUnt notre discours-euh
tout le temps et qu’on veut chasser
parce qu’ils poussent comme
une mauvaise herbe sur la pelouse.
Pourquoi dit-on « euh » ?
Parce qu'on commence une phrase
sans savoir quoi dire.
Facile.
Alors posez-vous.
Parlez moins vite.
Le seul désherbant possible
face à ces « euh »
qui poussent comme du chiendent,
croyez-moi, c’est l’art de parler moins
et surtout de parler lentement.
Érasme avait raison, comme toujours !
« Hâte-toi lentement. »
C'est la clé pour improviser sans déraper.
Oui, il faut savoir se taire !
Car c'est aussi la clé de l'éloquence.
L’éloquence, vous le savez très bien,
ce n’est pas seulement
trouver les bons mots.
Ce n’est pas seulement
l’art de bien parler,
c’est aussi convoquer
la puissance de ce qu’on appelle
le langage non verbal,
un langage qui ne dit mot
mais qui en dit beaucoup.
Avoir une bonne posture,
être bien ancré dans le sol,
se sentir solide,
avoir la gestuelle adéquate.
Vous regarder, vous, là, tous,
être avec vous,
vous sourire, pour vous offrir
une parole forte.
Ces mots-là ne sont pas des mots.
C’est un langage qui ne dit mot
mais qui en dit tellement.
Tellement.
Oui, le corps parle
et il est si expressif !
Une femme l’a particulièrement
bien compris.
Et cette femme, c’est Amanda Gorman,
une poétesse,
qui a déclamé ce poème,
« The Hill We Climb »,
lors de l’investiture de Joe Biden,
il n’y a pas si longtemps,
le 20 janvier 2021.
Il n’y a pas si longtemps, disais-je.
Et regardez, pourquoi est-elle
si intéressante,
cette femme déclamant son poème ?
Eh bien, parce qu’elle ne se contente pas
de réciter un texte.
Non, elle devient le poème,
elle est le poème.
Elle l'incarne, elle l'incarne totalement.
À tel point que très vite,
on n’écoute plus ce qu’elle dit.
Surtout s’il n’y a pas de sous-titres.
On n’écoute plus, mais on voit,
ses mots, ou plutôt son corps,
se déployer comme les ailes d’un oiseau,
de ces grands gestes
généreux et éloquents.
Regardez bien ses mains.
Regardez la poésie de ses mains.
Amanda Gorman réussit la prouesse
d’être tellement habitée par son propos
qu’elle l’incarne jusqu’au bout des mains,
jusqu’au bout des doigts.
Et le silence se fait.
Et le temps s'arrête.
Amanda Gorman nous rappelle
que l’éloquence du corps est aussi forte,
sinon plus parfois, que celle
de la parole, sans dire un mot.
Oui,
il faut savoir se taire !
Car l’éloquence est aussi
la clé du charisme.
Être bref est toujours
une bonne stratégie.
Cela évite de dire le mot de trop,
d'ennuyer son auditoire, de vous lasser.
Et c’était la conviction d’un homme
que vous connaissez tous,
le président Kennedy.
En effet, il avait à cœur
et on l’oublie parfois,
on ne le sait pas toujours,
il avait à cœur de faire
l’un des discours d’investiture
les plus courts
de l’histoire du XXᵉ siècle.
À tel point qu’il avait dit à sa plume,
Ted Sorensen :
« Attention, laisse tomber les questions
de politique intérieure.
Ce sera beaucoup plus efficace,
et je ne veux pas passer
pour un moulin à paroles. »
Il l’avait prévenu,
et Sorensen s’est accompli.
Et Kennedy a relevé le défi.
Il a effectivement prononcé, en 1961,
l’un des discours les plus courts
de l’histoire des présidents américains,
moins de quinze minutes,
dans la lignée de Lincoln et de Roosevelt,
eux aussi champions de la concision.
Et pourtant, on se souvient tous
de ce discours extraordinaire et bref,
on se souvient tous
de cette phrase mémorable
qui résonne peut-être
particulièrement aujourd’hui :
« Ne vous demandez pas
ce que votre pays peut faire pour vous.
Demandez-vous plutôt
ce que vous pouvez faire
pour votre pays. »
Alors comme Kennedy,
assumez la frustration de ne pas tout dire
pour piquer la curiosité de votre public,
lui donner envie d’en savoir plus.
Et comme au cinéma,
préférez plutôt un film court
qu’un film dont on dirait :
« C’était bien, mais il y avait
dix minutes de trop. »
Et parfois encore davantage.
Oui, il faut savoir se taire.
Car le silence est aussi
la clé de l'influence.
Le général de Gaulle est formel :
« La parole du chef est une parole rare. »
Il dit dans l’un de ses textes fondateurs
sur sa vision du commandement :
« Rien ne rehausse l’autorité
mieux que le silence. »
Et il ajoute :
« Aucun de ceux qui ont accompli
de grandes actions
ne les ont faites dans le bavardage. »
Intéressant.
On l'oublie parfois.
Certains l’oublient parfois.
D’autres pas,
comme par exemple la reine Elizabeth II.
Elle est un
des plus beaux exemples, je crois,
de ce que l’on peut appeler
l’art, justement, de la parole rare,
qui est la clé de l’influence.
Imaginez,
en 70 ans de règne,
la reine Élisabeth
n’aura parlé que sept fois
devant son peuple tout entier,
hormis les traditionnels vœux de Noël.
Sept fois, qui dit mieux ?
Ça fait en moyenne un discours
tous les dix ans.
C’est fou quand on y pense.
Quelle modestie, quelle humilité !
Elle avait sûrement envie de parler
plus, elle s’est retenue.
Elle a gardé le silence.
Elle a fait sienne cette devise
extraordinaire du peuple britannique :
« Never complain, never explain. »
« Ne jamais se plaindre,
ne jamais se justifier. »
Elle a compris l’importance
d’un silence politique assumé
pour préserver l’aura de la couronne,
l’aura de la monarchie.
C'était l'un de ses combats.
Mais allons plus loin.
Oui, il faut savoir se taire,
car le silence est aussi la
clé d’une bonne négociation.
Les Chinois le savent très bien.
Dans une négociation, le plus souvent,
le premier qui parle a perdu.
Et qu’est-ce que ça veut dire, négocier ?
Ça veut dire essayer d’obtenir
quelque chose de quelqu’un,
puis se taire en espérant
qu’il y consente.
Dans ce rapport de force,
un homme est passé maître,
et vous le reconnaîtrez, évidemment,
même s’il est ici voilé.
Il s’agit de Winston Churchill,
qui a été nommé Premier ministre
grâce au silence.
Faisons quelques pas en arrière,
si vous le voulez bien.
Nous sommes en mai 1940.
Hitler est aux portes de l'Angleterre.
Lord Chamberlain, qui est l’actuel
Premier ministre à l’époque,
démissionne.
Le poste est vacant.
L’heure est grave,
Il faut vite trouver un remplaçant.
Lord Halifax est pressenti.
Mais, et ce mais est important,
il doit obtenir l’assentiment du cabinet.
En l’occurrence l’approbation,
notamment, de Churchill.
Or, au moment où il doit
donner son consentement,
Churchill se tait.
Il choisit de rester muet.
Et ces deux minutes de silence
font basculer l’Histoire.
Se sentant désavoué,
Lord Halifax se retire
et c’est alors que Churchill est nommé.
C’est dire à quel point -
vous serez sans doute d’accord avec moi -
que le silence est une arme redoutable
en termes de pouvoir et d’efficacité.
Oui, il faut savoir se taire.
Car, vous l’avez compris,
le silence est la clé de l’éloquence.
Le silence est le sésame de l'influence.
Le silence est une arme redoutable
aussi en matière d'improvisation.
Mais c’est aussi, et j’ai gardé le silence
exprès sur ce point,
la condition sine qua non
d’un dialogue, du dialogue,
qui est au fond notre raison d’être.
Pourquoi parler sinon pour dialoguer ?
Or, comment réussir à se parler,
si nous oublions de nous écouter ?
Comment réussir à répondre
intelligemment à vos questions
si je ne prête pas attention
à vos propos ?
Comment trouver les mots de la nuance,
si je saute à pieds joints
dans les idées reçues,
faciles, rapides, sans réfléchir.
Le silence, assurément,
est une parole forte,
parfois même très forte.
C’est pourquoi, maintenant, je me tais.
(Applaudissements)